I've got some new tour dates to announce
I'll be in Las Vegas on June 30th and
July 2nd at The Encore Theater uh that's
right around they have a MMA they have
UFC that weekend we've also added a
sixth show in Austin on June 8th and a
fourth show in Houston on March 23rd
tickets for those shows are all on sale
now please buy through theovan.com tour
to make sure that you get fair and
accurate pricing and uh thank you guys
so much for all of your support it's
been awesome
all right we got some new merch to tell
you about uh we got the Vintage rat tea
the hunting club hoodies and hats if you
like to get out there with that
gunpowder
as well as some new colors in the bgty
be good to yourself collection get that
and more at
theovanstore.com and uh thanks for
wrapping
today's guest is that young leader
um he was named a Forbes 30 under 30
list uh he's a content creator prankster
um he's an entrepreneur
uh he's a uh co-founder of the nelk boys
and of the full send podcast I'm
grateful to be able to spend some time
with him today's guest is Mr Kyle
forgaard
[Music]
and I will find a song
thank you
[Applause]
I don't know I don't know if any like
people say stop drinking water past like
7 P.M or some [ __ ] yeah I just I love
water yeah I like it like people are
like yo you need to drink more water and
[ __ ] like they always complaining but I
I don't have that issue honestly yeah
I'm just the hydrated guy straight up
really yeah oh wow I'd say so that's
good yeah I think it's good do you like
to swim though
um
if it's hot out yeah yeah I'm not the
best swimmer but yeah I'll get in there
do a little front crawl yeah little
doggy paddle yeah I'm not the best
swimmer I'm usually kind of in the urban
section of the of the or whatever you
know what does that mean like people
that can't swim or I don't know I
wouldn't say that but I would say like
yeah if they had like a Memphis area of
the pool I think that's kind of where
I'm usually hanging out at you know like
I feel you when I get into the deep end
it is like I mean I I'm swimming with
every my legs become arms I'm using
every it's almost like I'm trying to
stay out of the water okay you know I
feel like so
um
Kyle forgard thanks for being here man
appreciate it bro yeah good to see you
dude so
um I just wanted to start some of my
audience are and some people in the
world I think you hear milk all the time
right so just what is it
um I guess there's there's different
layers to knock I guess with like the
content side and Elk is like you know
it's a group of guys basically just
doing stupid [ __ ] I guess people say
that we're this generation's jackass
which is like a huge compliment I'd say
too but I mean I think they do more like
crazier stunts like [ __ ] we could never
do and we're more like kind of pranks
and partying and just honestly just like
vlogging our life type [ __ ] and yeah we
have a big YouTube channel that has like
almost 8 million subscribers now which
we started 10 years ago wow so we have
that we're just uploading funny [ __ ] on
Instagram YouTube and then yeah the kind
of I think what separates us is like we
never really made a lot of money off
YouTube because we were quote unquote R
rated oh because they flag it because
they flagged it yeah so you know
everyone complains now like oh I don't
make money off YouTube yeah to me that's
like an old song and dance like we've
been dealing with that for like our
whole career so for me that's like
repetitive to hear now so but it was
kind of a blessing in disguise because
we had to get smart and kind of build
businesses or around our content in
order to like you know fund our
operation right so I think the fact that
we weren't making money like our fans
really no one understood it they're like
why like why can't they just find ads
that are like 18 plus or some [ __ ] but
and there was no ads ever so we kind of
just started our own businesses like
merch and yeah I think people really
[ __ ] with it you know we were kind of
like The Underdogs ah see so yeah there
was that yeah because like the send it
full sent all of that that became a lot
of y'alls that was like one of the merch
lines right yeah full send but okay
that's like something that I don't know
if we invented it but we kind of like
coined it yeah and [ __ ] and we started
saying it in videos and then it kind of
became something bigger than us yeah oh
I was at a funeral one time and the kid
was yeah it was like a like a 22 year
old dude who's getting buried and uh his
stepdad was like Sent send him he sent
it yeah yeah I was like damn bro [ __ ]
that funeral was probably lit I was like
[ __ ] turn up dude dude I was at a
funeral one time
um and they uh the DJ or whatever had
like a stroke or something in there dude
and he like when he hit the machine it
played like a Nelly song in the [ __ ]
uh in the uh service you know
what it was that song like apple bottom
jean you know what I'm talking about
that's low by T-Pain oh sorry so that's
what it was it was yeah so everybody's
just sitting there in people's crying
and stuff and [ __ ] Randall's dead
dude and every suddenly you just hear a
[ __ ] apple and people were like
what's going on and people were like
yelling like kind of pointing over that
area and the guy in there I mean it's
sad but he'd had a stroke you know and
you're like yeah because he was just you
know running I guess he had an electric
organ or whatever you know but that's I
don't know God sometimes like has like
funny stuff he does
um so how did elk start I just because I
think there's a lot of audience that
doesn't know you know so I just want my
audience to sometimes I don't do the
best job of like getting to know who the
guest is and where they're at you know
um yeah it started I mean I've just been
making videos ever since I was young
like grade five grade six just like
[ __ ] around with the camera making
like funny [ __ ] and then like little
even like short films and then um just
uploading them on Facebook and [ __ ] like
that I probably honestly if we found the
Facebook ones I think I'd be canceled
for sure like you know the humor back
then too like yeah he's like yeah you
probably do but like gay jokes could fly
and [ __ ] like crazy [ __ ] I remember what
we were doing but um [ __ ] like that just
messing around with Friends making funny
skits and [ __ ] and then getting into
YouTube
um and in high school I was kind of
always good at video like all sides of
video like the filmmaking side too like
editing directing and [ __ ] like that you
have to have your touch on it I think
especially if you're creative you have
to be able to do that kind of stuff that
was the thing with YouTube to everyone
that was coming up like you got to be
multi-layered you gotta have the
on-camera [ __ ] and then you gotta also
be able to be your own producer right
that's all the YouTubers that make it
kind of do both yeah so I was good at
both I always knew I was gonna do
something in film
um and I was like applying to go to film
school and [ __ ] and um but we started
uploading [ __ ] on YouTube and it slowly
started getting traction like 10K views
and then 50k views so huge 115k bro it's
sick and there was this thing um did you
jerk off you think did I jerk off to the
Views I mean not two of them but I think
I might have jerked my first YouTube
check it was like a grand probably
that thing's damp cuz bro it was lit and
it was like uh it was called like the
YouTube Partner program
and I saw like other YouTubers they were
like making a living off YouTube and I
was like no [ __ ] way you can like
make a living off YouTube like you just
get paid to upload [ __ ] YouTube
videos like yeah that sounds like the
dream to me so we kept applying we kept
getting denied and then eventually we
got it and so we would start making like
a thousand bucks a month two thousand
bucks a month you know like just enough
to kind of like you know just fund some
[ __ ] like do videos and [ __ ] and then I
think you're a business at that point
you become a businessman yeah I guess so
right like in a way it's like busy you
know it's like you start to create
something it makes some money and then
that's when you're like okay now this is
a business yeah so I was in film school
and [ __ ] and I told my parents I was
like I think the videos are getting like
you know 100 000 views and I was like yo
I think if I want to ever do be my own
boss and do anything in this [ __ ]
like genre or whatever I think this is
the way to go just like build my own
[ __ ] be my own boss and then I can kind
of do whatever I want when I kind of
make it right and what was their
response to that were they they believed
in me because yeah they they kind of
believed to me and they saw like the
money coming in I think it was like
Blind Faith to be honest which is cool
like a lot of people say like my parents
never [ __ ] supported me but mine was
like the opposite wow so it's pretty
cool but um and then we moved to LA I
say I worked at a golf course so I saved
up like all summer just [ __ ] slaving
at the golf course and were you meeting
was there some cool people you would see
at the golf course oh yeah it was like
all my buddies I think like actually
yeah four people that work for us now
they worked for me they worked with me
at the golf course really I got like six
of my Canadian buddies yeah from back
home and they all work with us now they
all live in Cali too wow which is sick
yeah yeah the golf course was lit though
we need more Canadian Imports too
because it's kind of not fair Mexican
does all these people you know there's
so many there's so many importing of
Mexicans right it's like there's a lot
of Canadians though too yeah but I'd
love to see a ton of them just rush over
the woods at one point you know what I'm
saying like one of those what's it
called those uh what did Trump call it
um when like a [ __ ] ton of them come
across oh yeah uh
[ __ ] what's the word like uh huh like a
wave no he called it something like it
was a really good name it was yeah can
you look it up for us that I think it's
like a quinceanera I don't know it
depends on how old they are
um but yeah one of those there's like a
huge yeah that would be pretty cool dude
if you had a bunch of Canadians roll in
dude we should kind of organize and then
they had to fight in [ __ ] like Ohio
or something yeah yeah and then what the
like ice has to go to the Canadian
border and like keep everyone out that'd
be pretty cool dude how weird will it
get when we have to hire Isis to come
protect our borders Isis or ice oh both
probably I mean it's getting pretty
dicey down there we had a border patrol
agent on and he said it's just crazy
really bro he said it's bananas he said
well first of all the cartels own a lot
of the land by the border are they like
hypothetically own it right so if you're
bringing across uh of an Ali I don't
know what we call illegal alien a
migrant somebody's coming in right then
you have to pay those the the cartels
have to be paid for you to use that part
of the land to get to the Border
um so there's all really so there's like
a whole there's little levels of
business that are going on on that side
right and then
a lot of times that you pay a certain
amount and they just guarantee that
they'll get you to the Border it's like
for like this is like Mexicans paying to
come to the US right wow and then you
gotta pay it's like an extra like
sometimes will hit you at the last
minute it's like 200 more if you want to
get oh you're like what the so the
cartel's making money off all these
people traveling trying to like escape
to the US right so it's just the whole
[ __ ] money grab it's a huge Racket
and then a lot of times they'll get
crazy they'll get people there and then
they um if they get busted a lot of
times the problem that the guy was
saying was that they don't Pro there's
no prosecution there's no follow-up by
the U.S so the Border Police will like
last storm or whatever I don't know how
they have to do it now but
um but then they don't get prosecuted so
like a month later it's the same dude
running across with like that [ __ ] to me
is like I'm Canadian too but I mean it's
so crazy that the US like isn't allowed
to have like a border I know I don't
know it's so to me like it's so dumb how
people don't understand that like it's
not like you're racist or anything it's
just like every country has to have a
border yeah you have to have like a
organized system yeah like Ronald Reagan
had a there was I think it was during
the Reagan Administration maybe Zach you
can look this up where they had you got
to sponsor someone who was coming across
so say you were a family that could take
care of yourself or that was big-hearted
you know you could say okay we're going
to sponsor ector you know or Oscar you
know and he's going to come stay with us
and we're gonna T you know he's gonna
have like a like a uh not like a parole
officer but almost like this social
parole officer here in the U.S so that
there's a level of um uh connection so
then like the the ice or whoever the the
authorities would have this American
person that's connected to the person
who's coming over right so it's kind of
like a program you know yeah I mean you
gotta have some sort of system right
yeah amnesty for illegal immigrants let
me see it at the Nations Yeah so
basically uh Ronald Reagan cracked down
on that but he did have a thing that if
you were in there before 1982 you at
amnesty which is kind of not protocol
for the right typically but um I think
you're right he did have like a program
where he kind of sponsored people there
was a program yeah anyway it's just been
interesting what went on down there but
um okay so we have milk you guys get it
put together in Canada right yeah and
then you're doing good now at that point
when you roll out of here and you decide
to come to La did your whole family come
no it was myself Jesse who used to be
with us yeah I love that and two other
guys yeah yeah so yeah Jesse came with
us too and
yeah I think I was like 19 at the time
I'm 28 now so it's almost 10 years ago
it's crazy to think of bro and yeah we
like just going to La you know like
landing at the airport you see the palm
trees like and um yeah we were pretty
broke at the time like we saved up money
and [ __ ] but also if you're Canadian you
can't sign a full year lease
because like you don't have a SIN number
or anything like that so we got rinsed
with the [ __ ] like short-term rental
[ __ ] too so it was like kind of
expensive to stay you know yeah yeah
because they bite you pretty hard on you
yeah so so we had to deal with that too
and then but yeah we we hit like our
first like viral video we did like the
coke prank on Cops I don't know if
you've ever seen that one we put like a
bunch of Coca-Cola oh yeah in the trunk
of a car yeah and then we like got put
we like parked in a suspicious area and
then we told the cops we had cocaine and
they arrested us and then they saw the
Coca-Cola that one has got like 50
million views now [ __ ] it's so crazy
yeah that was our first big one what is
something like that gets 50 million
views earn you like what can I earn you
want I don't think we didn't make
anything off that wow but theoretically
I guess
50 mil I mean some people make a
thousand per million at the lowest but
you could make
you can make like five thousand per
million so that could be anywhere from
50k to 250k wow but then it also just
gets your name out there which also has
just as much value yeah for sure either
way there's a lot of value with it yeah
I think I think honestly we might not
even be here if we got paid off YouTube
because you get really comfortable too
right a lot of those kids fell off that
like they were making a lot of money off
YouTube and now they're kind of nowhere
to be found so I hope they like saved up
money and [ __ ] yeah or you knock a chick
up you think it's a wrap yeah exactly um
you definitely kind of get used to that
um okay so then at what point does kind
of the the podcast you guys become this
do you and then I think we just like we
did uh six months La six months Canada
six months L.A because you had to
because we had to you can only be in the
country for six months and also we
couldn't really afford it so we go back
to Canada live at our parents house and
[ __ ] always slowed down when we went
home really because you're not around
like like-minded people and [ __ ] like
you're in LA and you're like dude we
went to a party once with [ __ ] like
our first time there like we ended it up
at like P Diddy's house yeah and [ __ ]
like you see like Bieber and Kendall
Jenner and like French Montana and [ __ ]
like just like random ass people like
Prince is a nice guy yeah he's cool yeah
um so it's just like and then you go
back home
and it's just like you know what I mean
you're going to visit your buddy yes
Farm or some [ __ ] yeah Arnold got a new
cat it's not the same as P Diddy you
know yeah it's like people watching
animals [ __ ] and they invite you over or
something's watching hockey back home
and [ __ ] yeah it's more chill people are
drinking in the garage 100 you know
everybody's afraid to beat their wife
yeah that kind of [ __ ] you know typical
Canadian [ __ ]
um
yeah that has so that had to be [ __ ]
wild then because you get so amped up
you guys are cruising and you go back
home yeah now but people started to look
at you guys as like freaking Young
Legends when you got back home huh they
did yeah it was cool I mean you go home
[ __ ] you're the hometown hero type
[ __ ] yeah all the chicks that you
couldn't smash you're still not smashing
them yet but you're getting closer every
time you go back home you get a little
little closer you're still like this
guy's a loser but yeah but God but um
yeah it was cool but yeah one time I
think we went home and we're almost just
like we almost just quit because we're
it's just like we weren't getting views
at the time too and it was just tough
um but then we just kind of we this is
when pranks were like a thing too I
don't know if you followed it but like
you know like Vitale oh yeah Roman
Atwood it was like almost killed a
hooker yeah Roman's a buddy uh Dennis
Rody those guys did almost kill a hooker
yeah was it a hooker I mean I don't know
somebody said he bit the neck open of a
hooker
can we look that up he just did I think
I saw a little bit I love Italy he's a
really nice guy but yeah he's just just
like shroomed out a little bit I think
Annie has that Russian element yeah he's
just a nut bar like he was always a nut
yeah but I loved Vitaly his videos were
so funny he's one of the persons that
like inspired me too but that was sad to
see
it was crazy right it's [ __ ] bro yeah I
don't know what he was on I would assume
he'd probably got into drugs I mean he
obviously he's a guy that likes to go
hard Russian people they want to do like
a lot of it seems like kind of Bud
activities and drugs yes and but you
know it's like they [ __ ] don't it's
like somebody came in at night and
[ __ ] made it took a slice of their
brain out and made a sandwich with it
you know and they're missing a [ __ ]
it's like a I can't even explain it
we're actually going to Russia this week
yeah I heard that actually we're going
to Dagestan damn so that's like out of
the danger zone it's like I think it's
like 20 hour flight away from Ukraine it
doesn't sound like it's out of the
danger zone I think it is I mean I don't
know we're gonna find out but we're
gonna link with hezboola you know him
yeah yeah so he's never met him yeah
he's a cool little dude is he he's
really cool yeah you you like I don't
know he's what is he 20 I think he's 20.
but uh I don't know just when we went to
Abu Dhabi just the like he's very
I don't know it's like he's his own boss
you would assume I mean you're kind of
judging him you think like he's like
kind of like a little baby yeah but like
he's not he's [ __ ] He's whipping out
his phone like going live and like he's
holding his phone like this like swiping
around like doing stuff he's on it yeah
wow
is it hard to not treat him like a kid
dude I felt bad for him like when we
went to the UFC it was just like I mean
this guy walks in a room every single
person in the room like you know if
you're a male female young or old
they're all asking him for a photo even
babies even a two-year-old would come up
to him everyone wants a photo with him
he's just like this this guy you know
and I actually I saw him I was like holy
[ __ ] I feel bad bro like this guy is
like
photos everywhere he goes
right people probably picking them up
and [ __ ] too I know little people hate
when you pick them up too yeah I think
as it unsettles their system Google that
if we can pick up a little one just even
like really short people like I used to
have this buddy that was short growing
up and he was the nicest guy but like if
someone picked him up yeah he'd [ __ ]
hate it he just like one time someone
picked him up and then like they put him
down he just [ __ ] snuffed him snuffed
him in the face that should be a UFC
fight where they just take small people
they somebody picks them up and then
sets them both these days that's what I
thought was gonna happen because
hezboola has a nemesis too right oh yeah
that little guy huh and he has bet that
what the the the little guy has the same
thing as him or it's a child I don't
know what this condition is or whatever
it is no but it's the same thing wow
same thing so he's like 20 or 21
whatever and they actually don't like
each other oh yeah so like they need to
fight yeah they've been saying it for
years this little guy's [ __ ] handsome
though kind of huh yeah he's a little
better looking yeah somebody said he was
he was like playing like a young Babe
Ruth he kind of looks like that he looks
like El Chapo kind of and the guy on the
right he's boys with Ronaldo
and then hezbollah's voice with khabib
so [ __ ] it's interesting bro it's kind
of cool though now since there's a lot
of celebrity boxing that I could see as
they get older they could do a tag match
or they could do you know what I'm
saying it's all gonna everything's gonna
end in the ring now in a weird way
because he got a UFC deal too hezboola
right did he really yeah I think he's
gonna be in like the video game or some
[ __ ] oh it's great but
that's wild can you imagine that
pay-per-view
I can't even imagine I would watch him
fight a cat dude I saw him get attacked
by two cats one time bro really yeah
oh it was [ __ ] crazy dude they uh
it's just so much more like house cats
oh yeah okay I mean that's like us
fighting a lion
I don't know Mr Scrappy yeah but it's
still the same thing if a [ __ ] what
did he do he must have he must have
destroyed the cats he went hard he
didn't do I mean he didn't do great but
he didn't do bad he always scratched up
a little bit oh definitely dude two cats
this is two cats it's four pm you should
have filmed that this was before they
even had this you didn't think to jump
in they did oh dude you were you were
honestly
you were laughing so hard the rest of
your body didn't work that was it's so
hard it's hard to be laughing
hysterically and like I think actively
jump yeah you know yeah
um but God yeah that was beautiful dude
it's not often you see [ __ ] like that
it's kind of like a sunset in a way
what the two cats attacking yeah just
seeing them all fight it is it's just
like a part of life I guess right yeah
yeah for them and you don't realize it
as a regular dude you see a cat you're
like oh whatever you know [ __ ] some
people yeah you know you know nobody
would say that but even some people will
but
um but yeah you see a cat you don't
think about it but a [ __ ] a little
person even if they come over to your
house dude and there's a uh there's like
a one of those a wiener dogs dude it's
on 100 now that's a fair fight I think
like little person versus wiener dog
just because of the
the the inability of the wiener dog to
probably Circle as easily you know I
don't know I think you're not giving
enough credit I I know I knew a few
little people and they're [ __ ]
they're kind of strong bro yeah like
they always have like big upper bodies
too do you notice that yeah
you know if you're looking for a new
gift that uh that will inspire somebody
and help broaden their life and Branch
their life out verbally then you want to
look at Babel that's right Babel is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million co uh subscriptions and
that's a lot think of 10 million people
learning something and think of it being
a language and Bam that's babble
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
with Babel you can choose from 14
different long washes including Spanish
French Italian and German plus Babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to
babbel.com
Theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash t-h-e-o for up to
55 off your subscription Babble language
for life you know I waste money on
different subscriptions I notice
you know I got a subscription the other
day I realized I'd accidentally
subscribed to it was like Sherman's uh
shoe strings or something and they start
sending it uh separate pairs of strings
you know shoe strings just you know you
got dang you know I got 90 feet of
street shoe strings at the house now and
I don't know what to do and I don't know
how to unsubscribe that's the problem
I'm wasting money on subscriptions like
that
you know eighty percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about it could
be an unused uh Amazon Prime account or
a Hulu account that never gets streamed
and that adds up that's why you need to
check out rocket money
it's the app that shows all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
what you don't want
rocket money can even find subscriptions
you didn't know you were paying for
you may you may even find out you've
been double charged for a subscription
to cancel a subscription all you have to
do is press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest
that's right right now cancel
unnecessary subscriptions with rocket
money today go to rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's
rocketmoney.com Theo
yeah I used to watch that show Little
People Big World all the time did you
ever see it no I hear about it it was
like this family
and actually used to do a bit about this
it was a family that owned a pumpkin
patch which was insane because it was
like the biggest vegetable in the world
right so like
there was like a family of small people
in Oregon and they owned a pumpkin patch
can you bring that up Zach
there they are
and half the family was little oh and
they slang pumpkins and the tall dude
smashes that thing
so so he's he's the only tall guy yeah
and the sisters who was tall I think
damn yeah
but they would like that'd be
interesting like I know being a little
person would be weird but what if you
like your father was like a little
person and you weren't oh you know what
I mean that's kind of I've never thought
about that I've never seen that before
actually I don't know that's just like
kind of interesting yeah this was a big
show for a long time and you just follow
the family but it was uh and the father
and mother always had discrepancies
um but yeah they had and they may have
one other son who who was regular-headed
but yeah that'd be so wild if your dad
was little because you always feel like
you were probably like going he's trying
to ground you and [ __ ] and you're like
Dad watch your tone and [ __ ] right yeah
you know what I mean yeah or if you come
home drunk one time you're like no way
like that just step aside like you're
not gonna do [ __ ] yeah
um it's kind of hot in here you hot I'm
good okay so what so take us through
what happens then so how does the
podcast kind of start do you partner up
with someone once you guys start getting
all this traction how do you kind of
like get your business to the next level
because now you want to you're on the
Forbes list right yes last year 30 uh
under 30. yeah that's unreal I actually
don't know what that means but all right
I feel like it's kind of political but
hey I'll [ __ ] take it right yeah I
don't know how it works like and is that
even you in that picture that's me
that's crazy it doesn't even look like
yeah I think that was a few years ago
okay yeah I don't know what Forbes 30
under 30 is but it sounds good right
yeah yeah yeah it sounds amazing but
it's like how to check set me up about
it and [ __ ] so oh yeah it sounds good
but I don't know how I got it but [ __ ]
it but how so how do you get from where
your channel is going well you guys are
doing well to like turning that into
like a bigger business yeah I guess I
guess the big play that for us was like
the happy Dad stuff for sure
um
our merch our merch was always killing
it too like oh yeah our merch was
killing it but um yeah happy dad's
something that I've definitely always
wanted to do because like my whole goal
is to like yeah I wanna I just want to
build like a big long-term business that
could like outlive me or let outlive
like anyone part of the crew you know
yeah just build something bigger but
yeah happy that we always wanted to do
our own alcohol because we're always
drinking and [ __ ] drinking in the videos
so we either wanted to get a deal or
start our own and we were repping Corona
a lot at the time but we were too edgy
to like get a deal from Corona like
which is crazy because Corona's Mexico
it's like have you [ __ ] been to
Mexico I know right yeah there's glass
in the sand but like no the alcohol
industry is like it's so it's so
political and so like you know in terms
of advertising so I understand like but
it kind of sucked yeah we wanted to do
something with Corona but they never did
it and then a few other people
approached us we used to be like WME and
they were trying to get us to like start
an alcohol but it never ever went
anywhere and then I met um I met John
and Sam John and Sam Shahidi had dinner
and they were interested in working with
us and they said yo like is there any
way we can help anything you guys need
help with and I just told them straight
up like I was like yo I want to start a
[ __ ] alcohol
I was like if you guys could do it if
you guys want to project manage that for
us I was like let's [ __ ] do it so
they found these uh these two guys the
the butau brothers and their family
they've been in like the alcohol
industry they're big drinkers wow for
sure we started taste testing it and
[ __ ] and it took us like a whole year so
we started from like a a point tested it
said change this changes change this
another test same [ __ ] and it took us
like eight different times over like a
year to get to like the product that we
have now that we really like wow and um
yeah that's just going crazy yeah oh
yeah people love having them you see it
all of you guys do a lot of those great
like drops and stuff where like you guys
will show up somewhere yeah uh Steve
will do it Steve shows up somewhere it's
a big shaking hands business alcohol
it's like an old school business is it
like yeah it's it's all about like
meeting store owners meeting bar owners
like you got to go and put in the work
physically yeah and like shake hands
meet people like the social media aspect
is one thing but like you gotta show up
places you gotta travel it's pretty
crazy it's old school business has it
been a lot big as once that became part
of it was did things get lot busier than
you expected for sure and then because
it used to just be milk we'd upload a
video like every week but then yeah with
happy Dad and then now the podcast too
it's like a lot of traveling moving
around especially with the Pod like if
we want to get the best guess sometimes
you only get 24 hours notice yeah like
if [ __ ] Elon Musk says like yo I want
to do this like we gotta fly to Texas
jump on a plane
wait around for a few days right you
just gotta be on the ball and be
prepared did you guys have to wait for
Elon we did yeah it was a funny story I
told it before but um
what happened was like we I think it was
Sam's birthday so we took a jet to Texas
um
and then we had no service so right when
we landed we got it was so crazy because
John got like two texts uh Steve's
channels deleted like YouTube these
channels deleted and the second message
was uh Elon message him and says why is
my security telling me that one of the
guys on your crew is a security threat
and we're like what like what are we
talk what are they talking about and
then they said like Stephen deal an
artist
and we're like what and then
um
then we kind of put it together Steve in
the past when Bitcoin crashed he made
like a funny video like [ __ ] on Elon
and he like blew up a Tesla uh-huh and I
think he was like he had like a
mannequin of Elon and he was like
shooting guns out of him
so like I guess the security they don't
know right they don't know her right
right and they probably think that's
they just see this guy shooting a
[ __ ] assault rifle at Elon and [ __ ]
and asking the flight the pilots like
what's his flight schedule and [ __ ]
so they saw that and they basically like
elon's like our whole team was set up at
his house like they they were with his
kids and like his one of his wives or
whatever and um they would they had to
leave and pack up and leave wow and then
Steve was like I feel so bad like and he
was also like so down about his channel
so he's like yo I'm gonna sit this one
out like I can't even do this anyway
like I'm so pissed off and then
um we kept messaging Elon back and forth
and like it went down like 48 hours
later he just ran him he was like maybe
he kept he just sounds like one or two
weird answers with periods every time
only by email too
and then eventually just like all right
let's do it and then he just pulled up
and he stayed for four hours no but it
almost it almost didn't go down and when
he pulled up who went to meet him first
did you just you were just sitting in
that room right there and he just walked
in just with one guy wow just walked in
and he probably crushed like six happy
dads no yeah he drinks a lot he's got
yeah he he's definitely an undercover
party here I don't even know about
undercover but oh I've heard some I
heard a great story a buddy of mine went
to like a party his whenever he worked
well I think whenever he was seeing like
Amber herds right
and he like asked him if he wanted some
spaghetti or something okay he asked my
buddy if he wanted some spaghetti and
he's like uh yeah I'll have some
spaghetti and so then he just like took
some off of his plate on a fork and like
put it in my buddy's mouth
really instead of like making him some
spaghetti like you know I think it
seemed like you want me to get you some
spaghetti he's he's a he's a different
kind of guy clearly right and maybe it
is more efficient maybe he's just all
about efficiency you know it's just like
it's probably more efficient if I just
give you some spaghetti that I have and
see if you want more spaghetti then go
get you a possibly wasteful amount of
spaghetti right you know but yeah my
buddy said that that was so crazy and
then there was a party where like people
would just kind of go around with like a
little drug cart and they had like
different like he's a big drug cart guy
for sure oh you I think you gotta be
dude he reaches his fingers in and kind
of you know takes his time makes a good
decision oh I bet he puts all the coke
out of the bag and touches it and then
puts it back in the bag probably oh God
mixes it up with uh some Molly
but always back home called out a
rattlesnake they do Molly and cocaine
together oh yeah rattlesnakes hmm
trying to think if I've ever done
anything like that
um
no I saw a guy get bit by rattlesnake
one time
I took with this dude Ronnie right and
he had some kind of I don't know he was
impaired or something but uh he couldn't
do he couldn't swallow right so like
whenever it was like we would do yard
work together and so whenever like he'd
you know get thirsty you'd have to
[ __ ] give him the water and then kind
of like you know he'd have to like kind
of maneuver him more you know sometimes
when we [ __ ] put that hose in him bro
and [ __ ] forget about it
we started playing a game of pool or
something and that dude's over there
Halfway to Heaven bro drowning out bruh
but that was a simpler time but
um so then that's really what took y'all
to another business level was doing that
yeah I think so because then you're an
alcohol brand then you're obviously a
bit you know you're like you're pushing
like
I mean you guys are everywhere that's
the big play I think that's our I mean I
know that's our billion dollar play
hopefully multi-billion dollar play if
we just keep the momentum going yeah but
it all comes down to we still got to
make funny videos we still got to do
what we've always been doing but I think
that's our big play for sure
does it feel harder to evolve like it
um do you think about how things need to
evolve because I find a lot of times I'm
like do I stay in this space that I'm in
and where things seem good and
comfortable
do I also recognize that like my
audience will be getting older as I get
older right and how do I manage that and
how do I even evolve as a person
sometimes I know it's tough right yeah
and then it's like you have your own
personal kind of life and your own
personal feelings but you put that aside
for the camera do you ever struggle with
that too like type [ __ ] like what people
want to see sometimes is maybe not
what you're actually kind of feeling off
camera type [ __ ]
I think I try to stay pretty clear on
kind of what's going on right because it
keeps me in a space but that's also this
is a channel where it's like kind of it
was kind of built that way whereas I
think yeah you guys are more of like a
entertainment we're here for sure
somebody's gonna die 100 [ __ ] you
know I think I think uh we used to do
every week on the main milk Channel
which was like our Vlog whatever but now
we're just doing like once a month
because it's just like yeah I think for
me now I've done it so long too where
it's not possible to do every week and
it's not possible to put out a fire
video every week so for me it's just
more satisfying now to do like one good
video a month you know yeah and do
something crazy like we're going to
[ __ ] Russia and like we're gonna see
hezboola khabib and Islam and [ __ ] and
like I think that's like a cool video
you know yeah we've done so much [ __ ]
we'll still do some pranks and stuff too
but are y'all taking signing with easy
to go he's not going because
um
he's not he we wouldn't give him first
class issues yeah yeah because it's like
fifteen thousand dollars I get it he
doesn't yeah but I get it yeah 100 but
he didn't even fly his girl first class
wasn't there a video he's like didn't he
didn't even fly some girl first class I
was going ahead he's a big he's a big
flexor that guy is he yeah do you I
don't know if you've seen any of his
[ __ ] but yeah he's a smaller guy isn't
he yeah he could wear a watcher on his
neck I bet I could see him being that
kind of guy we're like a Rolex neck he
like he rents chains off Jewelers like
he's he's a big flexor that guy but uh
yeah he tried he thought that we would
budge on the first class yeah so he told
us he's like I'm not going unless I get
first class and we're like okay dude
he's like we're gonna go film a fire
video like yeah you're not peace out and
then he's like oh what like they don't
want me to come and [ __ ] like you guys
don't want me to come we're like dude
like we can't pay 15K bro sorry like
it's a lot and he just started as like a
on-camera guy right he's picking up
Steve's underwear [ __ ] four months
ago there he is right there yeah he
seems like a decent guy huh yeah he's a
good guy yeah I like stunning but you
got to put in your work like you gotta
you know sure you don't get the 15 but
you don't get that out of the gate dude
unless you you know unless there's like
BTS [ __ ] gay activity going on you
100 you agree though right that's fair
steiny if he's watching yeah I think
it's very fair dude and he puts in a
year work and kills it then it's like
and kills it kills it yeah to get 50 I
mean that's a lot for a yeah it's a lot
and it's a far flight man
that's the thing too I think not just
tiny but yeah employees are on Talent
people get very comfortable very quickly
and the cloud people gets cloudy real
quick 100 that's kind of a tough thing
because I've long tried to find an
assistant and it's tough to find like uh
like an on-camera partner you know and
it's like it's tough because you like
tried a couple people and some of them
were kind of Cloudy you're like oh this
isn't they don't get it you don't have
an assistant right now I I feel like I
have the best assistant really he's like
he's gay in Brazilian oh wow I think I
think gay males make the best assistance
gay males not to be like sexist or
anything but because oh dude that look
I'm glad because like you know like a
girl if you're a girl like he can pick
up [ __ ] like he's still a guy yeah so
like if you have a female assistant
they'll use the female card sometimes
and be like yo I'm not picking up that
box like type [ __ ] so you got the guy
aspect he's strong he can do all that
[ __ ] but then if you're like sick or
some [ __ ] the feminine side comes out
and he'll you know he's asking me do I
want soup do I want tea with honey so
you got that perfect balance of like the
male female wow it's I think gay males
dude I love that I think it would be
nice to have you know what I mean yeah
and now I think you also now how tender
of a gay male could you have so he's
like the gay guy too where like I think
he's honestly like transphobic and [ __ ]
too oh okay so he's like he you know he
doesn't like guys that like paint their
nails and [ __ ] too yeah so we can still
like rip on gay people in front of him
yeah so like you know we don't gotta
change the way we talk and [ __ ] around
him too yeah you can still just feel
like a regular person yeah like I think
he's anti-pride and [ __ ] oh wow yeah
yeah so he's like a special type of gay
guy I like that dude yeah yeah I'm
trying to think of some of the if you
ever need him for a day I'll really just
let me know yeah if there's a big day
that you need him so like yeah he's good
I would try I think I might have seen
him by the urinal yeah same guy tall guy
ah no that that's just my buddy oh the
other guy the tan one yeah yeah I saw
him he's Brazilian yeah yeah dude
Brazilian and gay that's crazy I didn't
even know they were doing that
I mean that's a wild mix it is because
Brazil already seems like it has a lot
of just gay built into it there's a lot
of gay people in Brazil I wouldn't think
that though but out of there look it up
Zach
most gays
dude I remember we didn't you know
they didn't have a lot of gay uh because
gay being gay used to be a secret it was
like yeah kind of crazy how much has
changed I mean what was it not when did
it become legal in the U.S 2000 Obama
Obama legalized there right
probably yeah it was Obama but I think
in the black community they're not as
accepting of gays in a lot of ways they
call them punks yeah you know well all
the rappers would like they've dropped
like oh [ __ ] all the time like Lil
Wayne's dropped it so much they can be
50 cents he's always on it yeah yeah man
come on man
yeah I guess black people don't like gay
people yeah I think they just don't I
think it's just but that's why they need
that Conquistador gay dude that's what I
loved about Tiger King it was like all
right now right we gotta [ __ ] cause he's
gay right oh yeah now we gotta there's a
[ __ ] fly in the suit right here dude
yeah he was there right he was shooting
people and [ __ ] and doing drugs and
[ __ ] you know eating tiger meat and
[ __ ] he was doing it man he was like I'm
a [ __ ] gay boy you know he was like a
wild west yes that's fascinating yeah
yeah man do you think there's a lot of
and I know you probably see this more
because you're getting I mean you're how
much is your business worth now do they
say that
um I think happy that alone this year
will be worth
250 million wow valuation and that's a
that's awesome and congratulations
um but there's a lot of uh
wealth-induced homosexuality
what does that mean it means you get so
wealthy and you've had so many
opportunities with women gay it happened
in Rome it happened in Rome that people
were so powerful they'd had sex with all
the women that they started having sex
with men because you hear that a lot in
like Hollywood and [ __ ] right yeah like
I heard like P Diddy's gay or some [ __ ]
or like yeah you hear P Diddy who else
do you hear a lot of times Vin Diesel
really
because they just get bored they could
get any Chick they want so it's like a
new challenge like it's like a power
thing I think so well I think that's
part of it it's like once you get so
much women's the last thing you can you
know you're trying to sneak into a
dude's butt that don't want you
you know not to make it so but it's like
what's the last thing on Earth that I
can't get some straight dude you know
that's that's that's pretty weird
I hope I don't get that successful then
maybe maybe I do that's what I'm saying
it's like at a certain point that's
what's at the top yeah I think it just
happens it's like
you know because you've had everything
else you know you kind of get to this
other place
um which all which with uh the podcast
with the full Sim podcast right
you guys have had a decent amount of
turnover on there to say you think oh
yeah for sure what has it been like is
it hard to keep hosts is it that it's a
challenging show is it that I know you
guys travel around a lot and so people
need to be here and there what has been
like what has been some of the kind of
Journey with that I think at the
beginning we were just
kind of just having fun with it trying
new people and stuff like that obviously
we had the one incident with Bob which
like I kind of already talked about and
[ __ ] like that oh yeah I remember that
yeah that kind of like it is what it is
but I think that was like our only
real like big host change but we've
subbed in like Saleem or like Steve like
which we'll still continue to do and now
we got Brad that is on it most time too
so it yeah it is tough I think I think
we recorded like four episodes of the
Pod before we even released it because
we just didn't know anything about it
like we were just having fun with it
right yeah and then we finally found one
that we liked
um but yeah it is it's interesting the
podcast is fun though I love it because
it's something that I could do no matter
how old I get yeah right and you get to
meet so many [ __ ] cool people yeah
like Elon Trump like yeah what was that
like when when OJ when
um once Elon sat down with you were you
do you find is there a lead person who
kind of takes the lead and breaks the
ice do you kind of wait back it was it
was I kind of took lead a bit on that
one but yeah it was a bit awkward at the
beginning
because I was like you're kind of
nervous too right yeah I'm not like some
[ __ ] TV show host or some [ __ ] too
like it's Elon Musk I'm I'm pretty
[ __ ] nervous yeah straight I use
Twitter he oh you know it's like I use
the car yeah it's like I can't know how
to get I still can't know how to get
into a Tesla I know right you know I
still can't I don't do you like Teslas
or no I think once the truck comes out
if it ever does and that's the part that
pisses me off the most is that he hasn't
brought the truck out um
and I don't know why it's like what the
[ __ ] going on I just don't like Teslas
yeah other cars don't think they just
look kind of whatever yeah
I don't know they look kind of like a
bat it looks like if you get in there
it's gonna take you to meet some dude
yeah it's just I just don't [ __ ] with
Teslas I don't know I guess the whole
energy thing but I maybe I'm a scumbag I
just don't give a [ __ ] yeah I don't want
to run out of battery on the road like
you also don't want to tell you don't
want to hike to somebody's house in the
middle of the night like my battery's
down or whatever it's not it's not for
me I'd rather just go to the gas station
maybe I'm [ __ ] up the world but it is
what it is I don't know I don't know
sometimes I pour a little gas on the
outside of my [ __ ] car dude you know
I'm not always a good guy yeah like I
like the [ __ ] smell it now too oh
dude if you sit in one of those old cars
it's like a Chevelle or Chevrolet or you
know Chevy
and you [ __ ] there's one that just
when you get in it's like that and you
always you always hate you're always
dread going to the gas station yeah like
you're like [ __ ] I gotta get gas but
then when you're actually there and
you're filling it up it's kind of nice
you're kind of chilling it's kind of
therapeutic yeah you know what I mean
yeah but I hate getting gas like when
I'm like [ __ ] I gotta get gas but then
when you're there you're like this is
kind of dope actually like you're just
chilling you know it's yeah it's nice
and you sometimes you feel like oh maybe
I'll meet a chick here never happens but
sometimes never there's like a chance
it's always just some dude like some
dude who looks kind of like a mixed guy
and he's uh I feel like he's in like a
Celica or something and he's [ __ ]
pissed or he's busy yeah you know it's
some angry Middle Eastern dude I'm like
how how's every Middle Eastern dude
angry I know like can we get like seven
Middle Eastern nudes that are [ __ ]
police I know
um you can't [ __ ] around with Middle
Eastern people dude they're serious man
because I think they've been through
like they live in sand right
to live at the beach but nowhere near
the water is [ __ ] and it's not like
Arizona sand or like no it's like sand
yeah like a lot of sand right yeah some
of it's quicksand dude can you imagine
some of it's like hey guess what's in
here more sand yeah
that'd be [ __ ] dude that's like that
might be the worst way to die oh oh
would that be worse than drowning
I don't think you have time
I think you got a couple minutes how
fast does quicksand do
if we can look at a
yeah that's a good question you're
standing there quick saying it starts to
go and I think the suction kind of gets
you pretty good so and the more you move
the quicker it goes at least if you're
drowning you have a chance too right
like you're [ __ ] you can get through
it but quicksand you're just you're
[ __ ]
you gotta make a video and then you have
to throw your phone far so it doesn't go
down with you
you've seen one centimeter per second
one centimeter per second think about
that that's pretty fast how tall is
somebody
I don't I think that's irrelevant to
that it's just like one per second
oh it's kind of relevant yeah I think
it's pretty relevant because then you
see how many seconds you have but I
think people are like what 180
centimeters
so you get three minutes damn
dude bro that's some time bro
we should try that but like if there was
no way to die yeah do you know what I
mean that'd be like a cool challenge
it'd be a cool game show
dude I always wanted to make like this
kind of weird kind of Japanese style
game show where you get two guys to like
to like just real rural fellas you know
people that are just you know that
believe mostly in come you know and they
just eat as much as they want right for
a couple days
and then you set them up each in like a
tree and they both like defecate down
like a like onto a scale right and
whoever does the most wins like
something whoever shits the most yeah
but you don't see any of the [ __ ] or
anything it's like it's all kind of hid
maybe you see the shadow of It kind of
okay okay and you have like a hose so
not like see-through tubes yeah no
nothing it's nothing that you just see
the scale and that's what's really
publicized yes you see the scale and
there's like a host up there asking them
a couple questions you know what you got
left buddy you know come on Ronnie you
[ __ ] you know I like that I just think
that there was I think that that would
be kind of a fascinating little game
show because a lot of guys they
you know the best thing they can do is
[ __ ]
I feel like there's guys out there that
they feel like that's what they [ __ ]
do yeah I love I love a good [ __ ] oh I
spend I think too much time on the
[ __ ] do you really I think like I
just get like a lot of good work done
there and [ __ ] like when you're sitting
down to take a good [ __ ] yeah pull out
the phone like I don't know I'm kind of
creative on the shooter too like I'll
think of ideas there and [ __ ] I feel
like it's not a good [ __ ] unless your
legs fall asleep like right when you
start to get that tingle you're like all
right yeah it's time to wipe up yeah
it's time to [ __ ] tighten up yeah get
back out in the world 100
um I remember yeah one time defecating I
was in Cancun and some girl this was
during spring break came in and
um
just did sex on me right there when you
were [ __ ] in the bathroom yeah so
that's like a blumpkin no I don't know I
don't know where she's from I don't know
who she I don't know her last name so
you were on the [ __ ] yeah I was and
she started just like riding you or some
[ __ ] yeah it was a nightclub and
I probably could have been doing drugs I
don't remember but
yeah I remember that that's pretty
awesome that's I mean it's pretty
legendary story it was a lot man yeah in
the moment it was probably kind of weird
yeah it was a lot because I felt like it
was like a setup I'm like nobody would
do this
you know so it feels like you're like
getting set up or something you know I
gotta I gotta do that
I don't know but and also I think it was
the nightclub and it was like kind of it
they had like too many smoke machines in
there so there was like a lot of uh
Ambiance you know but I remember that
man I forgot all about that man praise
God that's pretty legendary though it
was something man you know you just
every now and then that's something
you know the light shines on you
you know 100
UFC 283 is taking the MMA action to the
next level this Saturday there are two
titles on the line and one bout is a
historic UFC match with figueredo facing
Moreno for the fourth time it's going to
be a banger check out DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of UFC new customers can bet
just five dollars and get two hundred
dollars in free bets
that's free bets instantly that's right
they're gonna have some crazy matchups
I'm so thankful that UFC is back I'm
sure you probably are as well download
the app now use code Theo new customers
bet five dollars on UFC 283 and get 200
in free bets instantly that's code Theo
this Saturday at DraftKings sports book
the official sports betting partner of
UFC minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details this new year you've got goals
and factor is here to help you achieve
each and every one of them save time and
have the energy you need to tackle
everything on your to-do list you know
what I'm saying with factors ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door imagine that knock knock who's
there dinner get factor and not only
skip the trip to the grocery store or
but skip the chopping the prepping the
julienning the shredding and cleaning up
too factors fresh never frozen meals are
ready in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy
no matter what your lifestyle Factor has
the meals to help you live it to the
fullest with keto calorie smart vegan
and veggie or veggie and Protein Plus
meals for people trying to beef out
they are on the menu each week and they
change constantly had to
factor75.com
Theo 60 and use code Theo 60 to get 60
off your first box that's
f-a-c-t-o-r the number seven the number
five.com slash t-h-e-o the number six
the number zero that's code Theo 60 at
factor75.com
Theo 60 to get sixty percent off your
first box
when you are when you guys want to see
Trump you guys want an Air Force One
right we did yeah and so what was that
it was pretty cool I mean especially
since I'm Canadian I don't know how many
Canadians have been on there right yeah
it's kind of cool I don't know
um but it was cool I I said before I
personally felt like the interior is
like a little outdated right like I feel
like they could get an interior designer
in there and [ __ ] it's big and [ __ ] it's
massive
but I feel like the interior designer
maybe should be fired or something or
does it look just more fan does it look
like it's kind of boring like your dad's
office yeah yeah yeah your dad's office
type Vibes and [ __ ] fault but it was
it's it was really cool like we were
supposed to interview Trump that time
this was right before the election too
wow like right before and then um so
people were hating them then was it the
first election yes so people were hating
him the second election first election
oh first election oh no sorry second
yeah yeah that's when people were really
really hating them yeah yeah exactly so
because at first he kind of represented
this Underdog type of thing you know
um well you think when he ran against
Clinton people didn't hate him as much I
think people hated him more the second
time second time but the media also
always hated him right you know I think
that he would have who somebody else
would have done a little bit better in
his position if they'd had a little I
don't know if he was the best speaker
but then also I don't know why we need
the who Trump's not the best speaker I
mean he's great but I don't know if he's
it connects to people that way I think
he's a good speaker I just think he has
a little too much like baggage
yeah totally for the average person
right like
yeah but when he made it that far I
remember when he got elected I was like
holy [ __ ] dude
any of us could be president crazy right
like [ __ ] I know no one thought he
was gonna win the first time I I was
shocked oh when he first came out in the
beginning I was like I think he's gonna
win because yeah look we went with Dana
and then we were supposed to interview
him right so we thought we were going to
interview him and then the last second
they came in they're like yo we're not
doing it and we're like [ __ ] they're
like yeah like Trump wants you guys to
come into his office though and like he
wants to meet you guys and [ __ ] we're
like and they're like you could film it
so like all right so we go in and like
Trump's watching [ __ ] like Ted Cruz
on the TV and he's like chirping them
like making fun of him and [ __ ] and then
they bring Trump on the TV and he's like
look guys look look how skinny I look
there look how skinny I look I was just
like no way he's exactly like TV in real
life and then he's just like oh look at
the look at these handsome guys like
such handsome guy like complimenting us
yeah
it was pretty crazy and then we went to
his rally uh-huh and he pulled us up on
stage for the [ __ ] YMCA the outro
like you know his way his getaway song
yeah he pulled us up on stage and we
ripped the YMCA with Trump and then he
he feed posted it on his Instagram
and we were [ __ ] hyped bro bro he's
never been to a YMCA in his life I know
he loves it he says it's the gay
national anthem right oh yeah but it's
just crazy that he's never but there's
no way that he's been a YMCA I know but
when he posts that on his Instagram we
were like holy [ __ ] bro like we're
shocked yeah it's like what the [ __ ]
just happened we're in another Air Force
One YMCA with Trump to like I can't
believe this [ __ ] like it's kind of
crazy how things can just start to
happen once things get going right and
you're like [ __ ] how am I in this crazy
scenario like I found myself at certain
people's homes or certain environments
and I'm like how am I involved in this
like we're going to Paris fashion week
next week and like it's like Mike Tyson
me Andrew Schultz were like gonna do
some Runway it's just like wow and it's
just like are you gonna like Walk The
Runway and chill yeah like for some
company I mean they're paying us you
know it's cool that's gonna be pretty
simple but it's also like how what the
[ __ ] is that even it's like what I know
right the opportunities that we get are
so weird and the people you get to meet
yeah I don't think you ever I guess you
get used to it but then you don't like
do you feel like used to it like meeting
you've met obviously so many people I
met like recently hitted on me oh I met
Leonardo DiCaprio one night oh yeah that
was a little bit
interesting probably I'd seen him a lot
at certain events he's always sitting
across talking real quietly to some girl
yeah but um he's always partying and
[ __ ] right yeah I don't see how he does
it but uh I thought that that was kind
of it was just interesting you know he
just smiled he's got all these lines and
he just like he has so much expression
you know yeah
um
yeah cool cat do you know him no I don't
know him but yeah he's like you know
he's like
yeah I mean he's like so handsome you're
just like oh I'm you know you're like
I'm not gay but damn buddy you know it's
crazy to people you get to meet it's
[ __ ] yeah it's so bizarre especially
with the fighting the UFC stuff that's
the part sometimes that's like a little
scary that's but you think so why are
you scared when you go there it's a
little bit because I know like I grew up
in a neighborhood where people are
always knocking the I mean people's dads
like I remember the first day in our
neighborhood this dude Milford was
fighting this senior citizen right in
the street Mr uh Polito was his name and
he threw him into a [ __ ] ditch fire
like into a [ __ ] ditch fire what's
that it's like a um I mean a fire in a
ditch but like yeah just a fire in a
ditch and um
yeah and he threw him right in that
[ __ ] dude and then right here's the
craziest part
he [ __ ] came out that [ __ ] though on
fire yeah people were [ __ ] cheering
did he stop drop and roll or just go
right back he went straight at him dude
he was like 200 Italian he went straight
[ __ ] at him bro I mean and people
were so excited people were just [ __ ]
and drinking Dr Pepper [ __ ] and
losing their [ __ ] crazy and uh
and yeah I think he threw him back in
man ugh but we just grew up in that
environment where people were always
fighting so you always knew that you
know you in order to get to another a
different part of our neighborhood
getting fight this one family it was
always like
you know they're always trolls under the
bridge you know and so I think there's
some of that energy with the with UFC
you think someone's gonna press you
there like jump out of the ring well the
most the people who are most enjoy
pressing or being pressed are all in
that building true and so I think it's
just a risk factor and everybody in the
fame is like an amateur you know in the
parking lot at those events it's just
[ __ ] people beating each other's keys
out of each other's hands true you know
um UFC sector who's your favorite
fighter it's so great
that fight was crazy you were there yeah
I saw you there yeah that fight was
insane Chandler versus Poirier that's
gotta be in the top I don't know what
but that was that was one of the best
fights I've ever seen in my life yeah
that was so [ __ ] sick to be there
how poorier pulled off the W yeah and I
thought he'd like yeah I think yeah it
was it's just fascinating to see those
guys Corey sanhagen I like Cheeto Vera
um sugar Shawn obviously
um they they might fight again right I
know because I think she Sean thought
he's like oh I got him it's done but
cheeto's like you ain't got me yet yeah
that'll be a crazy fight I know I know
because Cheeto I don't know if he cannot
cheat I mean Cheetos he's [ __ ] tough
yes he's tough as [ __ ] he's tough they
used to call him like the monkey he just
looks like scary bro yeah dude I went
and saw Zach Brian the Zac Ryan concert
right
um I'm a Hugh Jack Bryan fan and I go
there and I walk up kind of Backstage
and Cheeto [ __ ] bear is there yeah
you know and I you know Cheeto speaks
English good but it's like I don't know
if it's great enough to listen to Zach
Brian you know and so it's like it's
kind of random right it was it was the
most random thing in the whole world but
we hung out of the whole time man we had
a blast
so I don't know there's so many fighters
that I like man and then you get these
guys from like
like uh all the dagestanis yeah that's
why I'm pumped to go see because I feel
like no one's kind of seen how they like
live and train and [ __ ] right are y'all
gonna go to khabib's home something like
that would be so khabib's there I hope
we link with khabib that's a maybe but
we're gonna go see Islam and he's
training to fight volkanovsky so he's
five hours up in the mountains drive
from Dagestan
so he's like in the cold lakes and [ __ ]
and they're like living in cabins I've
seen it on his Instagram but I was
talking to their team today and it looks
like we're gonna go do it so I don't
know we'll try to train like them and
[ __ ] dude that's because you need to get
one of those missile launchers too and
shoot it yeah you know they all have
them
um but that would be amazing man yeah I
saw him jump into some ice water can you
bring up a picture of him
one of those guys I don't saw his last
fight in Abu Dhabi or did you watch it
was that the one where he fought Uh
Kevin Holland no default Oliveira
yeah he's a beast Islam now he seems
like an [ __ ] right I don't know if
he's an [ __ ] he seems pretty he's
kind of like they they play like the
they play like the modest card and [ __ ]
but they're always like dripped out in
Dior and like they dress like khabib
like drips hard does he yeah he's always
dripping and Islam too like he's always
like he's got dealer kicks on and [ __ ]
but then they play the modest card like
you know they know what they're doing
right I live in a sand castle Yeah Yeah
that's why maybe they don't they're kind
of hesitated paper yeah they're kind of
hesitant about us coming to
dagestan's going on I think they got it
made over there so I think now they're
looking on Airbnb and [ __ ] and like
they're gonna just like rent a cabin and
be like all right this is where we live
and [ __ ] you know but their real house
is like two blocks okay bib's got a
[ __ ] Mansion two mountains over yeah
yeah dude I that cause yeah I can't
imagine yeah for some reason with khabib
I have this idea of him like sleeping in
like his childhood bed still and his
grandmother's in the other room you know
making like no way though
cooking a rock or something you know
yeah but that's what you think but like
there's no way yeah like it's khabib
he's loaded
and there's nothing to spend money on
nothing he gets everything for free
because when you're famous there too
like if you're like Middle Eastern like
royalty
that's like next level [ __ ] right like
when you're worshiped over there I feel
like it's different than here have you
seen some wealth like that have you been
around some wealth you're like okay this
is some I don't know I've been to Abu
Dhabi twice and I just know those people
are so proud of the people that you know
because dagasan's kind of close to the
Middle East too right it's like right on
the southern part of Russia
I think we'll see yeah yeah I guess I
feel like they worship those guys too
like those guys are like he's like
especially in the Muslim like religion
too those guys are Gods like khabib's a
[ __ ] god to those people yeah so he
gets everything for free probably in Abu
Dhabi Dubai everywhere he goes like
Saudi probably
dude that's so crazy because that's like
another that's a world where there's
like you know even a chat like in the
shadows there's things going on
everyone's going there too now Middle
East do you notice that I see everyone
going to Dubai Saudi Arabia they're like
low-key they're they're taking over
low-key damn they're coming up bro
I'm kind of start to wonder what's gonna
come up next you know because America's
kind of become this like it's definitely
changing huh
Canada is worse bro I mean after the
whole coveted [ __ ] it was it was bad
there like Canada was fully locked down
for like two years wow like it was
[ __ ] and like when you go home too
like you notice like when I went home
one time like people like look at you
and like back away like it was like
oh people were brainwashed there
straight up it was very sad to see like
it was crazy and they're so nice there
they just they almost are willing to be
more brain but they turned into [ __ ]
quick yeah yeah but they were very
brainwashed too like covets on every TV
every news you walk into a restaurant
it's on the TV
it's it's crazy but I think that kind of
slowed us down a little bit and then
yeah I think people are just too [ __ ]
in North American culture right
yeah I mean in America is like I think
people didn't know what to do the media
really controlled A lot of that
narrative too and scared a lot of people
I think that's one thing we learned from
covet is like wow the media is powerful
yeah like it's actually scary
do you find I mean no Tech is the new
fossil fuel that's what I say all the
time it's like
whoever owns the bandwidth that's it you
know people keep talking about oil and
all this [ __ ] dude it's like
it's whoever owns the [ __ ] bandwidth
did you see that new GP Chat thing did
you see that thing what's that Zach see
if you can pull that up it was um I
think we were talking about it earlier
yeah I get to go out to dinner with
Jordan one time so he was his daughter
lives in Nashville right so he came in
and we all went to dinner and they eat
meat bro they eat like yeah at the end
of dinner it's just is he American or is
he from because he taught in Toronto
yeah he's Canadian oh is he yeah so they
eat meat and at the end of dinner there
was just literally a plate of bones in
between them damn meat and like seltzer
water really and I mean like a plate
they're serious about like they're just
what's just their like carnivores or
something yeah they're Dan carnivores
dude they're just like um North American
carnivores I guess or you know some type
of carnivore
yeah where we said yeah the media yeah I
guess yeah that's one thing I just
learned it's like
it's crazy like that's why I just feel
like there's just got to be some like
Elite level of people just like it feels
like it huh yeah because like they just
put something on a screen or like they
put it on our phones and then like we
look at it and like
we just believe it like isn't that crazy
yeah they could put anything on our
screens on our phones and you're just
gonna like you're gonna obey it's
[ __ ] nuts it's knowledge did you see
that show it's called don't pick up the
phone on Netflix no okay so this is
unbelievable so
some man right A man was calling
mcdonald's's okay or Hardee's but mostly
McDonald's
and he would talk to the manager right
and he would say hey this is uh
so-and-so with us on the police
department
um we have access to you guys closed
server kick cameras we saw that a staff
member had stolen some money right
um do you have a staff member that looks
like this and they would describe the
staff member
and then they would say yeah we do and
they would say okay can you have them
come into the office
so this this police officer is talking
to the manager the manager has a staff
person come in the office right it's a
woman and then the police officer is
like okay I'm gonna have to we're gonna
have to come down and strip search her
or you can do it for us over the phone
you can ask the employee what they want
so they asked the employee and employees
like well I'd rather have you do I know
you I don't want somebody to come down
here I don't know right
so then the guy's like okay we need you
to have her take her shirt off right and
it keeps going on until the employee is
like completely naked like bending over
spreading their ass spreading their
you know vagina you know Vegeta you know
the Geeks or whatever it's even called
um lifting their tits up right okay then
at one point right it's insane and all
this is on the cameras in the McDonald's
right so then at one point the managers
like I've been doing this for an hour
and 20 minutes with this employee I
gotta feed people breakfast out here and
the the officer's like is there anyone
else you trust that you could have
finish up the strip search right and
she's like well my fiance I guess he
could come down and help right
the manager's fiance comes down right
and is now on the phone with the police
officer this lady's been there naked for
an hour and a half
the officer's like yeah I need you to
like smell her body for like drugs and
then I need you to like have her lay
over your your knees is the officer a
real Earth is not real yeah and so but
these people don't know it it's like
this it's this system that happens in
your head when you get a little bit of
direction right and you start to follow
it and by the end this man is this man
who doesn't work in the McDonald's is
spanking this woman right
then the the officer says this is like
actually happened bro this happened in
like 50 locations
and there's a video about that there's a
documentary about it on Netflix okay
what's it called again it's called don't
pick up the phone okay bro I was
laughing so [ __ ] hard in the end this
girl gives the man a [ __ ] dude okay
that's gotta be fake no no they had it
right there the guy went to jail for it
what and all he was trying to do was
help his freaking wife who's a
McDonald's that's [ __ ] okay you gotta
be a bit dumb to believe that though
well you have to be but there's this
thing where it's like when you start to
believe a little bit what is that called
Zach
when you start to believe something a
little bit like uh no it's a it's a
system that's in there
but it was just a minute it's
unbelievable and finally like they they
start to figure out who this guy is and
uh I won't tell you what happens but
this guy I've been doing it for like 10
12 years wow he just got he just got a
kick out of it yeah [ __ ]
it's pretty fun it's kind of a good
prank call Bro unbel the the level that
it went to was just what if it just
started out as like a funny prank call
and then like he's like just kind of
[ __ ] with them and then they actually
did it I'm sure well people were blowing
each other people were
um
that a lot of instances here where
people smell in each other's butt uh
just things that were just really
graphic you know that's wild can you
imagine you're in McDonald's you're
getting strip searched you're [ __ ]
18. you could just quit bro well here's
the best part of that call is at one
point the janitor comes in right he
picked up the phone he listens to the
dude for like 10 seconds he's like oh
this guy's just [ __ ] playing around
yeah
[ __ ] McDonald's is [ __ ] I worked there
for like three shifts really back in the
day yeah yeah but it was so brutal like
I was just like [ __ ] this bro what was
your responsibilities there so it's so
weird like when you work in the kitchen
they make the newest person do like the
hardest job it's called like like batch
cooking or some [ __ ] and you gotta like
like the burgers are on one side of the
kitchen and then the fried [ __ ] like the
nuggets and the [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
the fun [ __ ] McChickens and [ __ ] that's
all on the other side of the kitchen and
you gotta like go back and forth and
like do both oh and it's only one person
that does it and like the managers are
up there just [ __ ] off like munching
on fries and [ __ ] just saying the
machine's broken yeah so it's like it
was it was pretty crazy and then like
some 40 year old was like bitching at me
like it was just like yeah I'm out and
then and then I went to work at the golf
course I'm just like [ __ ] off and
worked there did you see a lot of celebs
at the golf course that came through or
no actually my place no actually yeah
Will Smith came through there once
it's crazy uh and then Margot Robbie oh
yeah was she pretty she was smoking God
yeah and a golf skirt and [ __ ] too
getting hammered with her girls and [ __ ]
that's pretty crazy yeah someone's
always had more semen in my body than I
do yeah
um
what uh what was your experience I know
you guys had O.J Simpson on right take
me through the process of how you pull
in somebody like that and and was there
some was there some ethical questions if
I don't know you guys don't have a lot
of Ethics no we don't know but um
ethical questions
um yeah you know what I actually know
being real we actually did debate it
yeah we've had the opportunity for like
months like on maybe like a year
honestly and I think he has like a
right-hand guy oh yeah for us it's
usually like when the sun's a fan that's
how we get like mostly all our [ __ ] yeah
like if they have a male fan and he's 16
to whatever 20 something 28 he probably
knows us right yeah so OJ's right-hand
guy his son is a fan and I met him at a
like a Super Bowl party we were already
connected over email but yeah we were
talking about he's like I can get OJ for
you guys blah blah blah but the only
condition is like don't bring up the
trial right and that was like that was
the condition from day one don't bring
up like the trial nothing about 1990
whatever and we're like yeah yeah like
whatever and then we were debating it
like a lot of people on our team didn't
want to do it because we're like like we
asked like even like garyvee I think one
time too like what do you think about
this he's like nah don't do that like
don't touch that like and we're like
yeah so we were kind of scared of it too
because it is kind of [ __ ] up like you
know how would the family feel like
giving that guy a platform to talk but I
think the way we went about it was when
we decided to do it we're just like yo
like we're just gonna actually ask him
like the tough question too we're not
just gonna go there and not ask that
right that's a good point you know
that's actually a really great point
Yeah by asking him at least there's that
you're doing kind of what everybody
wants to do and at the end of the day
it's like I mean
it's not our fault like I don't know
it's the job like I'm not the justice
system like we let out like we had him
on and right that's what a podcast is I
would almost have almost anyone on it's
a good point I don't know if I believe
in the not giving someone a platform
thing
yeah I mean um personally I mean we've
had guys and you know guys that have had
sex you know crime issues in our you
know world and it's like
when do you know if a guy's getting
better or somebody or any type of thing
you know when do you know if a guy's
getting better
um and try to help them just be a part
of you know it's like be supportive it's
like if somebody were sick you try to
help them
um but with OJ was it like and I didn't
mean you guys don't have any ethics I
was just kind of clowning but do you
think um
when you saw him was it hard to get that
question out kind of it was so hard [ __ ]
because he walked in right away and like
you know he's big or not yeah he's tall
as shock nice nice sexy purple suit he's
looking fly comes in like he's talking
about golf like he's asking me where I
play golf and Cali like we play the same
courses and [ __ ] like you know what I
mean yeah we're talking about specific
holes like I'm like [ __ ] this guy's a
beauty oh because now you have a little
bit of a friend yeah like I'm like [ __ ]
I'm like all right shut up dude stop
being so stop being so [ __ ] yeah I'll
get the knife yeah I was like shut up
yeah and then we got into the Pod and
we're like you know again he was he's a
very likable guy which is clearly how he
you know he got he did what he did like
he's very charming and likable so yeah
but for that one I was just pounding
happy dads I I kind of treated it like a
prank like I was like [ __ ] like I didn't
want to do it but I just like I just
kept pounding happy dads well happy
dad's help someone ask a question they
don't want to ask you thing I mean
alcohol it's liquid courage right but
habitat specifically specifically I mean
electrolytes and [ __ ] it doesn't help
you out they did it yeah it definitely
doesn't hurt yeah it could almost be
like a thing that's capable of not sure
if your cousin killed somebody uh-huh
drink happy Dad yeah but yeah no it was
tough to ask
um but yeah I'm glad I did it because
people there's actually Artful it was
like do you think that wasn't like do
you think the murderer is still out
there or you've I I think I said first I
asked him if he's scared to face God
and then I said yeah like do you think
the Killer's still out there
yeah because it's like he's never really
went out and looked for have you ever
even went and looked for him like even
taking a walk but then after I read a
lot of comments like he's bad here
conspiracies and [ __ ] that his son did
it or some [ __ ] but the little fat son
I'm older now I don't know but
apparently like his son was involved or
something bring up the sun O.J son at
time of murder this is gonna be unreal
this is why I stay off Reddit but have
you seen that before I watched like all
the documentaries and [ __ ] and like it
was so bad like there was like eight
domestic violence calls like pictures of
the Nicole like beaten up it's pretty
sad man
oh yeah that's his son now maybe
no it's an old photo that's how it is
but yeah look at the group of the four
of them right there
you think that little kid did oh no way
oh yeah dude he would have to run and
put a knife yeah okay I don't know how
old he was but how much did that kid
weigh you think
he would have had to like have a sword
huh I think it was just a regular knife
yeah he that he definitely [ __ ] did
it I mean yeah zoom in on that kid Zach
I don't know no no chance look at his
face a little bit more let's get a
little closer on him
I mean no no chance
I think he's looking he does actually
does kind of look suspicious yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like oh we'll see
what happens next yeah he does look a
little suspicious
it's crazy man they say that um you know
that girl who died in Colorado her
brother killed her uh that famous little
beauty parlor girl
JonBenet Ramsey JonBenet Ramsey
at her brother killed her damn and he's
homoerotica thing
um did it end weird after you said that
to him after you talked about it was
there weird I think he I think he tried
to keep his cool we also pulled up in a
Ford Bronco
so
[ __ ] yeah and and we pulled up because
it was just for the video we didn't want
him to see us but then like he pulled up
at the same time and like he did like a
double look uh-oh like in like I thought
we almost blew it right then because
he's like what the [ __ ] are they doing
in a bronco
yeah it's murder what if you're
listening to that song you pulled out
dude yeah no he was cool after he kept
us cool I don't think he won he he's
very aware so I think he wanted to keep
his cool and not give a a good reaction
did you get a vibe that he had done it
no not really
like he's so it's hard to believe that
he did he's so likable and like cool
right yeah I mean it's hard to believe
anyone would kill someone so like you're
sitting across from a murderer you're
like did this guy actually kill someone
no matter who it is I guess
but no I I didn't get that vibe
but I don't know I mean it's it's it was
crazy it's hard to know people we got
some Flack for doing him but not not
that much most people liked it but some
people are like why the [ __ ] would you
give him a platform blah blah blah blah
blah but
I don't really give a [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] I think Ron Goldman's sister
started a podcast I believe the the man
that got killed with her with the wife
really yeah the wife was beautiful the
wife of who with uh OJ's wife Oh Nicole
Brown and her friend there was a guy Ron
Goldman that got killed too yeah that
people forget about a lot and uh
damn
crazy bro yeah I kind of know if I could
do it man I don't think I could kill
like I think I could put the knife in
somebody I couldn't pull it out stabbing
is kind of [ __ ] I could probably pop
someone with a gun yeah but I think you
gotta stab him if you're gonna do it you
think yeah it's more like Rome it's like
you know like Caesar kind of like I feel
like you have to
at least do it like you'll never even
know what it like at least if you're
stabbing them you're part of like the
culture I feel like even I'd lean more
to like like a rear naked choke type
[ __ ] choke him till the end just I feel
like I could do that but like the
stabbing is just like
that's [ __ ] yeah you got to really mean
it you know what I mean yeah yeah I mean
you gotta mean it man that's the thing I
think it would have to even like pushing
them off like
a tall building that's insane bro that's
easier though like it's just it's just
kind of like a push and then you then
you just cut but like stabbing's like
you're kind of you gotta commit to it
the whole way yeah it's like a longer
moment yeah
yeah maybe if you did like I mean you
[ __ ] pushed them yeah I would do the
fake Call for him uh-huh I think you did
something you know or just randomly put
something there you're gonna trip on
like oh that's crazy yeah
why did somebody put this uh why did
Tony put this bowling ball right here
um Zach can you get that audio working I
just wanted to look at that yeah I got
it here all right thank you very much
you're talking about chat gbt which if
you for people don't know that's the AI
right that makes stories out like it can
make Tech stories out of anything
Tech stories you know just showing you
like what is like kind of the future of
even like class work and stuff could be
like oh no
yeah GB
okay you make it bigger not very many so
I'll tell you what child GPT is just so
you know because you need to know this
and I don't know what sort of
technological Revolution this is
Gutenberg Press level it's something
like that this is a big deal so this AI
system to General language processing
model was released about a week ago a
week and a half ago and uh I I went and
interacted with it you can it's an AI
system artificial intelligence system it
basically is trained on well a massive
Corpus of of spoken and or of text of
course so it's derived its models of the
world from the analysis of human speech
essentially it isn't using real world
data yet
but that will be happening certainly
within the next year
so
and chat GPT analyzes a very large
Corpus of text and that Corpus is
growing all the time
now it's already sophisticated enough I
went on to it last week and I said okay
some of you know I've written these
books 12 rules for life and then beyond
order 12 more rules because you know you
can't have enough rules and
I asked if this is what I asked it to do
I said write me an essay
that's a 13th rule for Beyond order
written in a style that combines the
King James Bible with the doubting
that's a pretty difficult
that's pretty difficult to pull off you
know any one of those things is hard the
intersection of all three that's
impossible well it wrote it in about
three seconds four pages long and it
isn't obvious to me for better or worse
that I would be able to tell that I
didn't write it
right right and okay that's crazy
although you know maybe that's crazy I
mean just to think that like you go put
your information you know
the AI shit's crazy you can like hey
write this novel for me write this story
I mean it might not be great but you'd
have like you'd almost have your
Ghostwriter right there create like half
of the work that's why I'm trying to
like
be successful and make my money in the
next like five or whatever years before
this ship becomes like mainstream right
because then at that point it feels like
there's not even gonna be any value to
Being Human anymore no like and I feel
like to compete in society you're gonna
need to like do this type of stuff or
have like a neural link right that's the
other thing too but yeah the Elon Musk
like whatever in the brain like the the
most successful people are gonna they're
gonna do the this [ __ ] I just don't want
to be a part of that [ __ ] at all yeah
nah I don't want to narrow Link in my
brain would you get one
I don't know I think if you helped me
sleep I would probably get it true I
mean the medical benefits are like
that's pretty crazy if there are some
does it say there are I mean that's kind
of half of it yeah too I think he said
like it can like cure like Alzheimer's
and stuff like that and like I think he
even said like cure like
paralyzed [ __ ] yeah so I mean that if
that's true that's insane but I think
just the fact of everyone having like
something in their brain like that's
[ __ ] yeah
like the like then the government has
right they they're in your brain like
are they like that thing's probably
downloading info like is it even the
government anymore I feel like the
government is like a shell LLC for like
whatever bigger darker [ __ ] money
licking lizards are out there you know
yeah I feel like there's just some big
lizard licking a nickel somewhere in a
[ __ ] bed what's that thing called
reptilians or whatever or some [ __ ] yeah
I think yeah people believe I think it's
some of that like some you know
reptilian Kings or whatever but it
starts to feel like something's [ __ ]
going on that's what I think sometimes I
think that like secretly like aliens are
like running the world yeah like I feel
like they're on Earth and they're like I
don't know if they're disguised or
whatever but I just feel like humans are
just so easily manipulated
I feel like they came here and said like
we need to live here but there's like
this species here that we need to
control yeah and like they just taught
us how to act like humans
and now they're just they're just kind
of controlling us type [ __ ] I don't know
that's what it feels like sometimes
because like yeah we're smart but we're
not that smart no and we're not that
individual as we think you know we kind
of think we are but then it's like we
look at the news we all look at the same
seven news stories every day it's all
very we all go to like four websites now
remember when there were so many
websites like shoes and pussy.net right
it was everything and then now it's just
like you know ESPN [ __ ] you know yeah
they don't people even go to Yahoo
anymore people used to go to that but
it's like it's just like there's just
ESPN
like there's not even like there's
nothing dude I'll be on ESPN and go type
ESPN again like crazy just add ESPN plus
that's it yeah there's like yeah and
that's it it's like you know or there's
betting it's like it's just gambling
it's Disney owns [ __ ] everything now
too like it's all gotten really strange
it's all gotten just so like there's not
like any like it's all just gotten down
to like three or four companies
um yeah I sometimes think that we don't
see any aliens anymore because aliens
like they were here a long time like
they come to Earth and like these people
are [ __ ] lame like they're still
walking around they're still [ __ ] in
like little like a little like uh
ornament you know like they're out of
their minds true right I know things
that we take for granted or things that
we do so normally yeah imagine if there
was like another species watching us and
they're like what the [ __ ] why do they
do why are they doing this like imagine
us we observe animals and say like oh
that's so interesting how they do that
like we do the same weird type of [ __ ]
that if there was a more intelligent
species they'd be like why the [ __ ] do
they they do this yeah you know yeah
we're their nature Channel dude they're
like oh this guy's bringing leftovers
this guy's driving from the Italian
restaurant with half of a [ __ ] veal
parmigiana in his back seat right with
his wife who won't shut the [ __ ] up I
know you know he hates her but he won't
leave her like that [ __ ] like yeah dude
or she hates him or she has like some
buzzer underwear that's like touching
her puss the whole time it's just like
what is he and like that's why I think
aliens don't even come here anymore it's
because they like they know back home
like that place is a [ __ ] dump like
they're like it's almost like if you go
to like you want to go to Toledo you
know no offense but you know I got
tetanus there from um just just looking
opening my eyes in the city but it's
like
um it's just like they're not even
coming here if like if you're shitty
alien parents are taking you to [ __ ]
Earth on your [ __ ] alien vacation
dude you're so lame I know it's crazy
with the I don't know what's I don't
know what our [ __ ] future is yeah I
feel like it's all gonna go to shits
before it gets better like we're too far
gone I think yeah I don't know how it
gets back I mean people have lost their
sense of like American idealism I think
is kind of gone you know most of the
like smaller cities and stuff kind of
struggle but then there's still a lot of
like people there that care about each
other and stuff so I think if [ __ ] hit
the fan cities would kind of get [ __ ]
up first because people in cities are
going to pop each other cities kill each
other yeah they're going to kill each
other you don't want to be in the city
but towns will band together you know
counties and small rural area they'll
[ __ ] band together for sure you know
and they'll have a lot of weapons yeah
like Middle America and like yeah when
you go to those places It's pretty dope
yeah people are just chilling they're
eating [ __ ] pie dude they're wanting
to [ __ ] each other but they can't yeah
you know because somebody's you know
that's what because I don't know if you
know but like Canadians hate Americans
really yeah Canadians hate Americans
like when I when I like that was the
thing before like Canadians don't like
Americans why they think they're like
arrogant or whatever type [ __ ] yeah but
um yeah I don't know I I found it cool
like when I used to go to like the
Southern States first like when I would
go to like Georgia or like even I don't
know I just feel people are really nice
there I find too like yeah the southern
states and like the real like American
oh yes people are [ __ ] really nice
yeah people are people it's a lot yeah
America's awesome man I mean there's a
lot of great places we get stuck in
these like spaces where we just hear
[ __ ] out of New York and La where people
are just more concerned about like
they're a you know
they feel like they don't need America
anymore like they're better they're so
stupid it's [ __ ] dumb dude so dumb
it's so dumb man that's one thing I
liked how like I moved to Nashville a
couple years ago a year and a half ago
is that where you like live yeah that's
dope and it's been great man it's like
you get to see yeah Tennessee didn't
they didn't budge at all right dude that
[ __ ] was wide open during the vaccine
yeah there were people [ __ ] eating
vaccine I mean no people there were
people [ __ ] eating covet dude I saw
what you said like what do you what do
we do with our fake vax cards oh yeah
dude that's funny it's true right like
yeah
what do we do with them yeah like they
throw them out like are you gonna need
it again one day I don't know but that
was yeah I don't yeah the whole thing is
fun it just I don't know and it wastes a
lot of people's time that's the worst
part the thing I hate the most about
that kova was like if there was like
women out there who were looking for
love or something you know and they're
getting all you know it's like it kind
of separate a lot of people like that
you know it's [ __ ] crazy thank God
it's over though yeah dude if they try
to do it again people are gonna get shot
I think yeah you know I know I I don't
know I don't know what's gonna happen in
the next 10 years or some [ __ ] I think
it's gonna be crazy what is um some of
you guys business plans before you get
out of here man what are some of y'all's
business plans like moving forward like
so you see this you have this product
you got you're working well with these
Shahidi guys you guys have um do you
still feel like a creative or do you
start to feel like a businessman
um what's some of that feel like both I
think that's definitely like one of the
the struggles is like you got to do the
Creative [ __ ] and you still gotta do the
business [ __ ] too right I enjoy both but
um yeah definitely it definitely is
tough
um I think yeah we're just gonna try to
continue to grow happy Dad we're gonna
like double our states we're in 16
States so we're gonna be in probably 32
by the end of the year oh sweet we're
gonna launch Canada which I'm pumped
about dude that's gonna be insane it's
gonna be insane like it's gonna be
that's gonna be like a dream come true
for me it's gonna be crazy lots of
freaking beverage in your own country
that's so ill you've been up there or no
yeah dude I've probably done a ton of
shows right Toronto best Toronto world
best posture yeah well with people oh
you see people in Toronto
you could barely see him dude I've never
noticed that oh it's a clean line of
human damn you could barely see him
anywhere in the whole world are you
going there anytime soon or no yeah I'll
probably go we're doing a bunch of shows
we just we sold like 10 000 tickets in
New York we sold wow to one show well I
like to do a few different ones yeah
that's it I like a small I would rather
keep a smaller venue yeah than do
because it just feels a little more
intimate hell yeah you know you get some
of those bigger places it definitely
seems neater but then the people are so
far away you feel like you don't even
know them yeah you know but yeah we've
got we've been doing great so I think
yeah we'll get up to Canada man we're
gonna go to Calgary Regina we're going
to damself have you been there
Saskatchewan dude I've never been there
you haven't I've been to Edmonton yeah I
used to go to Edmonton get food
poisoning up there that's pretty greasy
up there right yeah it's [ __ ] uh a
lot of people just drinking oil and
trying to [ __ ] each other yeah it's
pretty cool and then like you gotta I
don't want to be racist but like the you
gotta watch out for the natives there
too really I mean yeah they don't [ __ ]
around like you can't [ __ ] around with
them oh wow really yeah they'll [ __ ] you
up
[Music]
in Edmonton wow yeah you gotta you gotta
be careful and do they like are they on
they're not on Horseback or whatever
like her oh they're just kind of they're
just there smoking darts like having a
cigarette and they'll just they'll [ __ ]
you up if you like look at them wrong
and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
we should get that sanctioned huh yeah
dude they should have a little bit of
like native verse white do it over you
know like in the UFC yes do something or
at least like a small field battle you
know when I was growing up we'd go out
there to the cwrs out there to the Civil
War reenactments and we get out there
and somebody's daddy would be in it you
know and there'd always be some [ __ ]
chicks out there trying to [ __ ] smash
like some of the generals and [ __ ] but
uh that was a big thing in the South you
know the Civil Warrior enactments yeah
that's crazy it was huge man I remember
we go they'd have six 700 people out
there reenacting wow yeah
that's crazy get out there people are
eating somebody's got a horn somebody's
[ __ ]
coming out there in the distance
drinking Dr Pepper bro I'm praying
uh God I miss it
but
um California what if any suggestions
you have and it's kind of a general
question you get all the time but for
somebody that's kind of like trying to
get into the digital space now somebody
that's looking to like find their way
find their Lane is there any thoughts
you would have kind of for them like
what is that I think the new age now is
like you probably know too but it's all
about the clipping [ __ ] now right like
even on even on your pod I see your
clips
all the time yeah you guys too that's
how I keep up with Brad it's how I know
what Steiny's doing you know it's like
it helps right so I think I think the
most the best thing you can do now is to
be like shareable
right I think you know whatever you're
doing just like how is someone that
doesn't know you or doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you like what's gonna make them
want to watch your [ __ ] or what's going
to make someone want to show a friend
your thing right yeah there's got to be
something to it like
right like your [ __ ] people share
because it's funny yeah like you you
know someone's gonna be like yo look
this is funny like you got to be you got
to be shareable like if you look at your
piece of content and there's no reason
to share it you're not gonna grow
especially now it's not like before
there's so many people doing it like you
got to really stand out right yeah you
can't be boring you gotta
yeah you have to find I think what is
your unique thing yeah and also editing
can be key so if you have a good editor
or if you have a good eye for your own
stuff like I remember when I first went
to colleges I didn't have a full hour of
Comedy right right so I would go and I
would show up the day before and I would
do like a uh cribs like with like the
principal of the school or like the
fraternity house yeah and then I would
edit and I would interview people on
campus and I would edit it that night
and so then the next day I would do a
little bit more and fantasy editing and
then uh when it came time for the show
time I had like this 20 minute intro
video where it was like cut together it
looked like like a shitty cribs kind of
but it was like the principle you know
or like those jokes and then like that
shit's still on YouTube no I never put
any of that I'll see if I can find some
of that that sounds funny it was pretty
cool but then I had like suddenly I had
like a 20 minute opener and then I would
do 25 minutes of comedy and now and then
I'd do like 15 q a and now I have an
hour show 100 but it was like you I
learned how to do like those things you
know and like at least no
what I was going to be kind of a domain
over you know and how I like to navigate
humor and clips and you can edit stuff
together too to make things funny no
matter what yeah and now I think you
should stop going viral for a bit on
YouTube like remember when [ __ ] used to
go crazy yeah I were like the [ __ ]
yeah you guys Charlie bit my finger like
no but anyone could upload a video on
cannibalism or whatever yeah exactly
people eating each other and [ __ ] right
they would allow anything before well
they had one video of a guy making love
to a dog in a park dude that was up
penetration yeah bro it was crazy that
[ __ ] was out there
it's crazy it's just porn and [ __ ] well
it makes you wonder if we'd ever get
back to that you know where see some
guys just staying warm with a [ __ ]
Saint Bernard and you respect it yeah
getting a blowy from a golden retriever
I mean that's a little crazy but I mean
I mean that's you know they're gonna
stay loyal right
dude I'm her first time I saw a golden
retriever dude I'd never seen a dog
inside someone's house before right so
I'm over at my buddies dude in this
[ __ ] dog comes around the corner
right and I was like oh I mean it was
just a beautiful golden oh just blonde
hair beautiful [ __ ] blonde hair I
mean it looked like
it kind of looked like uh
like Suzanne Summers she was like this
older model bring her up look like
Suzanne I mean it came around and it
[ __ ] looked like somebody like loved
it or whatever
and I just remember being like my god
dude it looked like her right
[ __ ] yeah
but I'd never seen it I've never seen a
dog indoors every dog I've been around
was Outdoor Dog you know and they died
out there
I mean they lived out there too yeah but
um dude thanks so much for just coming
in like yeah I think it's really helpful
for everybody to kind of learn about
what the network boys is what the full
send is what it's like kind of just uh
what your Journey's been like man yeah I
know I appreciate you having me I gotta
come I want to come to some shows man
yeah we've never been yeah I've seen a
ton of your [ __ ] online but we gotta we
gotta come see some shows live yeah dude
definitely we'll get you to one for sure
I'm supposed to hopefully start doing
some stuff with UFC I'm trying so really
yeah I want to try to start we're trying
to start figuring some stuff out so
anything you could say or no no it's
just we're still like in the incubator
stages that's sick it would just be yeah
I just like I just love it so much every
time I'm there Christmas you know
even like somewhat like some commentary
type [ __ ] or like I can't say just like
that just gets me excited we're figuring
out the involvement you know we're
trying to figure out what it could be
because God I'm just so [ __ ] oh it
just dude you should you should do that
that'd be sick I'm trying man it just
feels so good when we're there you know
um thanks so much bro for coming in dude
I gotta come on uh full sun soon yes
let's do it when you're back all right
let's do it hell yeah all right bro
[Music]
[Music]
I can feel it in my bones
gonna take